the CBS all access series The Stand
wrapped up its nine episode season and
two episodes a showstopper appropriately
tied toward the stand and a quieter
epilogue made up of largely new material
titled the circle closes here are some
of the most confusing aspects of the
ending of the stand explained
once Glenn Ray and Larry finally make it
to Randall flag's evil empire in Las
Vegas to make their final stand they are
immediately arrested and put on trial
Glenn tragically never survives a
courtroom and Rey and Larry are
subsequently sentenced to death via
drowning the pair of chained to the
bottom of an empty pool as it slowly
fills with water in front of a crowd of
Spectators but before Larry and Rey can
meet their watery end thick clouds
gather over the building's Central
Atrium and start zapping people with
lightning bolts soon the lightning
coalesces into a floating ball it
finishes by repeatedly zapping flag
himself then destroying everything
including Larry and Rey by detonating a
nuclear warhead safe to say that was no
ordinary Lightning in the book although
the circumstances are a bit different
the Warhead is detonated by a hand of
God described as a giant glowing hand in
the sky if you look closely as the
clouds wrap around flagg's building they
do resemble fingers meaning that the
lightning was basically Divine in
intervention given the strong spiritual
themes in the series it's fitting that
an act of God would be the thing that
would finally take out Flack at least
for the time being
although four sets out from Boulder to
Las Vegas only three arrive safely Stu
Redmond breaks his leg on Route and is
Left Behind with Glenn's dog Kojak some
travel supplies and enough pain meds to
either take the edge off for a few days
or provide stew with a Swift and
painless exit however it never comes to
that it turns out that Dana georgian's
desperate warning notes to Tom Cullen
was successful despite his illiteracy
after hiding from flag's henchmen under
a pile of dead bodies Tom was able to
escape Las Vegas and started the Long
Walk toward Boulder on his way back
Tom's attention is drawn by Kojak whom
he joyfully follows while we never see
Tom's reunion with stew we can infer it
happens when stew finally makes it back
to Boulder time to save my life ready by
the time they make it back stew is
walking and is clear from Franny's
narration that a fair amount of time has
passed in the book this time Gap is
explained by Tom nursing stew back to
health in a hunting lodge aided by the
ghosts of Nick Andros in the show we'll
just have to use our imaginations
one of the creepiest subplots in the
stand is Nadine's Supernatural pregnancy
fathered by Randall Flagg now Dean
encountered a flag in a vision while she
was crossing the desert to get to Las
Vegas and they finally consummated their
disturbing relationship with him
transforming into a horrific demon
mid-act after arriving in Vegas it
didn't take very long for Nadine to
realize she was pregnant with flag's
Offspring who or what was just dating
inside Nadine's womb will always be left
to view his imaginations but we can at
least venture to say that it wasn't a
healthy baby human for one thing Nadine
went from being a virgin to seemingly
nine months pregnant in the span of just
a few days for another it was clear from
the dean's corpse-like appearance and
the sharp movements beneath her skin
that whatever was inside her was
consuming her from the inside out Nadine
finally realized that she was never
intended to survive the birth and throws
herself from flag's Penthouse window
from flag's devastated reaction we can
assume that whatever Nadine was about to
give birth to was instrumental to his
plan and was most likely intended to be
the Demonic successor to flag himself
fortunately for everyone that plan never
came to fruition
although the stand is filled with human
characters it is ultimately about a war
between Cosmic forces of Good and Evil
on the side of good representing the
will of God is Mother Abigail and on the
side of evil there is Randall Flagg
burden like mother Abigail who is
uniquely gifted but undeniably human
flag is something else not only can he
fly but he can also apparently
regenerate after being repeatedly struck
by lightning and then vaporized by a
nuclear blast to call flag of the devil
is probably both the right answer and an
oversimplification mother Abigail
alludes to the idea that he is actually
the son of the devil he simply showed
you what he thought would scare you into
doing his will
he says Father's son
and he tempted you however in Stephen
King's books flag is more of an ageless
malevolent wizard who repeatedly shows
up to push characters toward Darkness so
in the broader scope of King's Works
flag is both a sort of living devil and
also something else a little more human
in the stand however the character leans
more heavily into the devil Persona both
in how some of his actions mirror
biblical stories and in his demands to
be worshiped
the trashcan man is one of the more
enigmatic characters in The Stand
characterized only by his Pyromania and
an erratic behavior that indicates some
sort of neurodivergence he's introduced
well into the series and is tasked with
retrieving a nuclear warhead that flag
intends to drop on the boulder free zone
but instead the trashcan man covered in
radiation Burns drives a warhead into
Flags hotel where it is then detonated
by the hand of God in the miniseries
there's no explanation given for the
trashcan man's odd behavior he seems to
think he's doing flag a favor but we
never get any context as to why in the
book though it's a little more fleshed
out the trashcan man brings flag the
bomb to make up for accidentally wiping
out a big chunk of his air force that
scene never happens on the mini-series
so the trashcan man's motivations are
much more vague taking him at his word
he simply misunderstands what flag wants
him to do with the Warhead and things
that make sense to bring it straight to
his leader whoops after Stu and Franny
decide to depart Boulder for Maine they
poured in Nebraska to rest and restock
taking up residents in an abandoned
Farmhouse only the cornfield outside the
house isn't as abandoned as they think a
young woman is staying in a tent in the
field at first the girl's presence seems
ominous but later once she helps Stu
save Franny and then miraculously heals
Franny's wounds it's clear she's on the
side of good the implication is that
she's a reincarnated version of mother
Abigail or at least someone like her
chosen by God to possess special gifts
her presence has never really explained
and she vanishes when Stu and Franny are
safe again considering that flag has
shown to still be alive at the end of
the series introducing the girl shows
that there is also still someone like
mother Abigail in the world to help her
balance him out as mother Abigail tells
Franny the wheel keeps turning this
jungle continues
but the command
is always the same history will continue
to repeat and evil will never be fully
defeated but mother Abigail's pointers
at resistance should never end either
the girl seems to show that as long as
there is evil there will also be
powerful good
after tumbling into a well Franny dreams
of encountering flag in a forest there
he names her biggest fears that she will
die of her injuries leaving her baby to
die of exposure and that stew will die
in an accident before he can get back to
them but he offers her a way to prevent
that outcome if she'll give him just one
thing I would like a kiss
he explains that the kiss will give him
the ability to see through her eyes
every now and then for a second it looks
like Franny may give in but then she
makes her choice clear not for my
husband
for the world itself
get thee behind me you [ __ ] bastard
while the transition obviously takes a
bit of Liberty Franny is actually
quoting the Bible in the Book of Matthew
when the devil tempts Jesus in the
desert just like the devil in the story
flag offers Franny everything her heart
desires and just like Jesus Franny
refuses to be tempted in doing so Franny
finally gets to make her own stand
against evil
similarly to how Franny's last
confrontation with flag is heavy with
Biblical references so is her final
conversation with Mother Abigail after
praising Franny for resisting the
temptation of evil mother Abigail tells
her that she will have five children
twenty grandchildren and 70
great-grandchildren your children will
replenish the Earth this also mirrors a
story in the Bible in the Book of
Genesis God rewards Abram's faithfulness
by telling him that his family will
become a great nation and that they
shall become the recipients of the
promised land the parallel is clear by
rejecting flag Franny has been blessed
by God for great things she knows that
taking a stand against evil isn't a
one-time action but that even in the
face of hardship her instruction is
clear
[Music]
and be true
stand
after the dust of Las Vegas has settled
at the end of the stand it's easy to
wonder what was the point why did Mother
Abigail bother sending the four
representatives there if the city was
going to be blown up in a nuclear blast
anyway even the hearts Larry and Rey
were changing right at the end didn't
ultimately seem to matter since those
people died along with the rest of the
inhabitants of Las Vegas obviously it's
hard to say what would have happened if
the quartet had never set out for Vegas
but it's possible that the only reason
the hand of God appeared over Flags
Casino was because of the demonstration
of Faith from Larry Ray and Glenn by
refusing to bow to flag they
demonstrated conviction and Faith to the
people of Las Vegas that Faith then
spread to others who would have
otherwise been complacent many of the
Stan's themes are about the power of
resisting evil even if the personal cost
is high so even though Larry Ray and
Glenn died their commitment to
righteousness was likely the thing that
saved their friends
the final moments of the stands are a
bit disturbing as flag stumbles into a
village isolated from both the modern
world and the deadly superflow after
killing a member of the tribe flag
levitates and introduces himself my name
is Russell Faraday
clear that the cycle is beginning yet
again flag will continue to corrupt and
gain power wherever he can and it will
be up to the good people of the world to
resist his influence the new name he
gives himself is especially interesting
a far a day cage it's an enclosure used
to block electromagnetic fields which
seem significant considering flag was
defeated by a ball of divine lightning
calling himself Faraday feels almost
like a challenge to God insisting that
the next time God comes after him he'll
be ready
after Franny stew and baby Abigail leave
we never learn what happens for the rest
of the growing population of Boulder
however before Franny and Stu leave they
talk about how it seems as though it's
only a matter of time before all of the
familiar voices and failings of human
society creep inside the town's peaceful
borders this Echoes what Franny says
earlier in her musing that she's not
sure humanity is capable of picking a
better path than before even with a
complete reset and is repeated again
toward the end of the episode when
mother Abigail talks about the
repetitive nature of human history so
what does that mean for Boulder it means
that they will get back to normal with
all that normal entails it means the
residents will find happiness and
friendship and love but that there will
also be pain and bitterness and violence
it means that they won't get a happy
ending but they also won't get a sad one
because as Franny says truth is most
stories don't end at all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos by
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]